that when we give we give the police a
power of God we allow them to take life
say something it's not straight down the
middle of the line and they're going to
get you I'm incapable of selling out I'm
incapable I think the cops should feel
threatened because I feel threatened I
grew up threatened by the police and as
far as anybody out there it should be an
equal thing they should know that they
can't just step to you and take your
life without retaliation you know so
it's like we're all human beings I don't
care if you got a badge or anything
nobody should be able to treat anybody
like this it worried about these
particular breakfast
[Music]
you know but if you really know why
don't they move because they can't touch
me they can Boyd they don't buy my
records anyway so they think they know
they can not possibly touch me without
killing me
and basically my song Allen is directing
the enemies on that Apple are racist
people the KKK parents no matter what
race you are if you teach racism to your
kids and rule police and if those are my
enemies Sophia yeah I didn't care
I prefer brothers just like myself
things bought the game in the quest of
extreme wealth were told legit
organization right
[Applause]
we needed that when we give free time
you know it's like when they will this
is they they are really really
frightening about it now some one of the
boys said well should they be scared
yes they sophisticated cuz I'm spirited
Emily you know I think y'all should have
a little fear on each other we can't
have anybody taking advantage of anybody
a cop cannot walk up to a man and feel
that he is so powerful that she was on
Italian especially
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we shut this record down you don't
shut my next record dick cuz I'm gonna
talk crazy or I'm gonna talk about this
record on an x-ray you know everybody in
here who's taking a picture with you
because really they're active work
because there were you know so what's up
basically they know they got the laser
across here is only a new me because I'm
not gonna stop talking and telling the
truth I'm incapable okay
the record was done a year ago when we
laid the record we put this little vein
about Rodney King on it cuz that was
coming at the time
what we saw today because we know what
was going on I don't know what this for
the objective is with only option to
feeling I'm not going to just enough to
talk about myself to like I still happy
and I deal with everything and basically
me personally as an artist you know no
but you guys they come in to get you
they're coming to get you say something
it's not straight down the line
among those people who know what's real
and know we're tired of it and as
efficient as an artist you know we work
inside for up organization call the
music industry we know how it is then
because I don't like to be innovative
demonym I hear a whole bunch of mobile
economy now advisories move for my own
flat but they were they trying to do
with me
it shut down my platform they do not
want to let me be able to speak to the
masses that's what they want to do
there's no way we can say what we want
you got a free to speak with watch what
you say it's so funny when the riots
broke out
ask me questions like why I study well
mom how do you feel about right Marshall
long I prefer to add retracting how do
you know about the Congress third album
for track 15 you know it's like I'm so
ahead of what these people have been to
net they can't put the new I'm basically
damaged you if you live to me I know I
know that you know I heard somebody one
time I said there's no way to succeed
there's definite way to failure and
that's trying to make everybody act I'm
trying to make everybody back let me try
to make those who maybe see it's simpler
than we are willing to listen and do all
the other piece and all your own life
you